on Sunday for the second time Puerto
Rico voted in favor of becoming an
American state Puerto Rico is a
territory of the US with a population of
3.4 million about the size of
Connecticut's population Puerto Ricans
are of course US citizens Puerto Rico is
part of the US but it is not a state
they pay federal taxes except federal
personal income tax and since Puerto
Rico is not a state it does not have
voting representation in Congress it
doesn't get electoral votes in
presidential elections this was the
fifth referendum of its kind held in
Puerto Rico
these are non-binding votes the first
was in 1967 and if we look at the most
recent three in 98 there was 71 percent
voter turnout forty-seven percent voted
for statehood in 2012 there was 78
percent voter turnout sixty-one percent
voted for statehood and this weekend
with a low 23 percent voter turnout 97
percent of Puerto Rican voters opted for
statehood this as a result of the low
voter turnout is probably not going to
be taken too seriously by American
lawmakers who would need to actually
agree to make Puerto Rico a state
however because of the 97 percent result
the current governor of Puerto Rico Riki
Rosello has said that he's going to
appoint two members of the Puerto Rican
Senate and five members of their house
to go to Washington DC and request that
Puerto Rico become a state under article
4 section 3 of the Constitution our
Congress has the power to admit a new
state to the Union with a joint
resolution of both houses of Congress
but I don't think this is really going
to go anywhere the decision will
ultimately be up to a
republican-controlled Congress and it is
not particularly likely that they are
going to want to make this happen
Puerto Rico also has 74 billion dollars
in debt to the US government not the
type of thing that Republicans in the
House or Senate would be too keen on
taking on of course because making
Puerto Rico a state would mean giving
them two senators likely going to go
democratic also five House seats and you
to draw those seats from other states
because you're locked in at 435 right so
that may mean taking one away from a big
red state like Texas you're generally
right which is that Puerto Rico would be
democratic but it is not this 90 99
percent progressive Haven that some in
the US think it is they say oh it's a
100 percent spanish-speaking Latino
territory so of course it would be
overwhelmingly blue it would become the
bluest state in the Union there are
conservative elements or conservative
ish elements in Puerto Rico their
governor is a member of the conservative
NPP party
two-thirds of Puerto Rico's Senate and
two-thirds of their house are controlled
by that party so yes it's likely that it
would be democratic in the general
American sense but it would not be this
ultra left bloc that I think some
Americans think it would be of course
Puerto Rico can't vote up in the general
elections for president but they are
able to vote in the primary yes again
I'm going off of memory here but I think
twice as many people voted for
Democratic candidates Hillary Clinton
Bernie Sanders then did the Republicans
and Marco Rubio who is a moderate in
that field about everyone yeah yeah yes
so liberal but maybe not as liberal as
some might imagine it now what is my
view on this
I support Puerto Rico becoming either a
state or an independent country a US
territory the u.s. one Puerto Rico in a
war until 1898 Puerto Rico was a colony
of Spain Spain lost the spanish-american
war in 1898 and gave Puerto Rico and
Guam to the u.s. I genuinely don't like
this I think that the US should be the
one to say listen this in between status
it's not really appropriate in 2017
choose independence or choose statehood
and we will grant you one or the other
not everybody agrees though some people
say hey Puerto Rico gets some of the
benefits of being part of the US without
some of the bad parts I guess I don't
know it really is one of the last
remnants of American imperialism and you
have to wonder what this would mean for
our other territories like Guam and
American Samoa and the US Virgin Islands
and also we'd have to make a 51 state
flag have you seen a 51 state flag it
doesn't look too good does it look like
unbalanced I don't like this well if the
assist
I'm more concerned about the aesthetic
of the flag rather than whether it's
right to keep Puerto Rico in this limbo
that's fair yeah I know you have
artistic sensibilities but I'm less
worried about that we'll figure out a
spot for the star you know I'm just
unwilling to change you know send me
your thoughts what do you think about
Puerto Rican statehood